alors la balance des inconvénients c'est
quoi c'est un impact limité sur
l'environnement qui est jugé acceptable
tant par les experts montréal que par
les experts du ministère de
l'environnement et de la faune pour un
danger plus graves à l'approvisionnement
en eau potable alternatif c'est de
mettre en danger la station d'épuration
d'eau la ville de montréal et
l'approvisionnement en eau potable
si on ne veut pas de l'art avec cette
solution là dans l'état prescrit par des
experts
c'est l'alimentation en eau potable de
montréal sera en péril monsieur le
président si ces travaux ne sont pas
fait de la façon que les experts la
ville de montréal
les experts du ministère d'environnement
le disent les experts du ministère de la
faune de 10 les experts scientifiques
sciences et experts et les experte
indépendante la science de lille c'est
l'approvisionnement en eau potable de
l'île de montréal qui est en péril les
eaux usées que je vous remercie
lapsus